are you lonely up late then call me
because I can't sleep and I want to talk
to you just pick up your phone I'll be
up all night in fact I haven't had a
good night's sleep in months I have a
sleeping disorder I've tried everything
even black-market ambien my doctors
can't figure out what's wrong with me
[Music]
sleep was starting to affect my mind I
[Music]
went to a state-of-the-art sleep clinic
to get a more thorough diagnosis they
told me I have irreversible neurological
damage from having too much thank sex
the kind of sex we'll be talking about
when you call me Oh was your fantasy my
fantasy is never having to make a call
like this Tiffany I'm afraid you have
less than six hours to live better call
soon $4.99 a minute to ambition was
forbidden fantasies call one nine
hundred hot xxx and for a free MRI and
consultation converse
sling clinic at 1 973 nine three eight
six or one 906 fun remember it's one
nine hundred hot xxx four steamy phone
sex and one nine hundred sex fun for a
diagnostic neurological scan percent off
use the promo code orgasm that's for the
sleep clinic not for the phone sex line
please don't call our sleep clinic if
you're masturbating
[Applause]
you